les médias nous manipule t-il c'est une
question qui m'interpelle et qui
m'intéresse depuis plusieurs années puis
plus de dix ans désormais par rapport à
laquelle j'ai eu l'occasion et
l'opportunité d'écrire plusieurs
articles et plusieurs ouvrages
ça me touche c'est une question qui me
touche d'autant plus qu' elle touche à
la confiance à la fiabilité
pour moi c'est primordial de savoir dans
ma vie en qui je peux croire en quoi je
peux me fier en qui je peux avoir
confiance
déjà en 2009 on mémoire lorsque je
faisais mes études concerné l'esprit
critique des jeunes par rapport à la
fiabilité des sources sur internet
j'ai continué ensuite ce travail de
partage et de réflexion autour de
l'influencé de la fiabilité des médias
en alimentant un blog qui est devenu
aujourd'hui mon site fil aux médias
point b e
j'ai constaté en 2011 que l'article le
plus consulté de ce site concerné
justement l'influencé la fiabilité des
médias en allant un peu plus loin j'ai
constaté que les thermes de recherche
introduit par les personnes qui
arrivaient sur cet article
c'étaient les médias nomment antilles
les médias nous manipule t-il les médias
noteront peut-il et ça me fait sourire
ça me fait sourire parce que lorsque je
m'interrogeais que je me demande
ces personnes sont elles les plus
perméables aux messages des médias
j'ai tendance à croire que non et ces
personnes au contraire sont peut-être un
indicateur que le processus d'influencé
de manipulation c'est quelque chose de
complexe
alors j'aurai envie de décortiquer avec
vous la question les médianes
manipulative et la première chose qui me
vient la première chose qui me frappe
lorsque je l'entends ou que je la
formule comme tel c'est qu'il y a d'une
part les médias et d'autre part nous des
machines en tout cas des instances
abstraite sans visages d'un côté et nous
un e et 1 nous des médias et des humains
je reviendrai sur ce propos parce que
pour moi c'est l'essentiel puisque
j'aurai envie de partager avec vous les
médias nous manipule t-il nous pouvons
aussi décortiqués ce que signifie le
terme manipuler et j'aurais envie de
postuler avec vous de poser qu'il s'agit
d'influencer les opinions les médias
influence-t-il nos opinions il ya des
réponses à ces questions depuis que les
médias de masse sont étudiées depuis des
dizaines d'années lazarsfeld et youcam
richard hoggart ont pu mettre en
évidence que les messages des médias de
masse avait relativement peu d'
influence sur nos opinions ce qui prime
au contraire ce sont nos opinions
préalable nous avons plutôt tendance à
défendre nos opinions préalable et
lorsque nous changeons d'avis nous
sommes plus volontiers influencé par nos
groupes d'appartenance les individus
auxquels nous nous référons nos proches
ce que nous considérons comme nos
semblables
plutôt que les messages des médias de
masse et c'est daniel schneidermann qui
utilise une métaphore que j'aime bien
pour illustrer ce phénomène c'est la
métaphore du circuit électrique
l'idée de cette métaphore c'est que les
messages des médias n'atteignent
efficacement les publics que lorsqu'ils
sont véhiculées par un matériau qu'on
acteur au sein de la société qui lie à
un fil conducteur au niveau des gens si
je prends par exemple le cas du fact
checking le fact checking la
vérification des faits qui est
institutionnalisée par plusieurs médias
d'information et bien il y à fort à
parier que les personnes qui considèrent
que les médias nous trompent nous
manipulent
ils sont au service d'un pouvoir
corrompu elles prennent un contre pied
des messages de ces médias elle s'y
oppose
peu importe les messages voire même
elles ne vont même pas les consulter et
probablement sans doute avec les
algorithmes et je ne vais pas
m'appesantir là dessus et que ces
personnes ne vont même pas être
confronté à ses messages
est ce à dire que les médias ne change
pas du tout nos opinions nos
représentations du monde je n'irai pas
jusque là bien sûr une autre thèse qui
m'intéresse c'est la thèse de l'agenda
setting de macao
que nous dit cette thèse elle nous dit
que les médias auraient moins d'
influence sur ce que nous pensons que
sur ce à quoi nous pensons c'est à dire
au thème auquel nous accordons de
l'importance
en fait les médias alimente nos sujets
de conversation dans nos sphères
d'appartenance de nouveau que nous
regardions le dernier talk-show de
divertissement que nous regardions un
débat télévisé sur une chaîne dite
culturelle que nous regardions un clash
entre deux vidéastes amateurs ou
professionnels sur un média social
finalement usages que l'on en fait est
relativement similaire
nous alimentons nos conversations avec
nos proches et la réception c'est pas du
tout quelque chose de neutre
maintenant cette thèse nous dit aussi
que
il y à des thèmes valoriser dans
l'espace public
il ya des thèmes auxquels de l'
importance est accordée et il ya des
thèmes peut être occultée et je pose la
question des thèmes comme l'immigration
la laïcité en france ont tendance à
préoccuper les français si l'on en croit
certains sondages
ces thèmes préoccuperait t-il autant les
françaises et les français s'ils étaient
moins mis en avant par les médias
là c'est difficile de savoir évidemment
uea poulets well et l'oeuf
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que en faisant
écho à ce thème
et bien il y a une importance qui est
donné peut-être au détriment d'autres
pays tout cela pour dire que l'
influence sur les opinions c'est un
phénomène complexe
c'est pas phénomène linéaire puisque je
vous ai parlé du circuit électrique
c'est plutôt un ensemble d'aller retour
entre des médias dits de masse et une
société un des pics c'est pas un
phénomène immédiat non plus trop souvent
on a tendance à réduire l'influencé des
médias à très très très court terme
comme si demain ils pouvaient changer
radicalement nos opinions
comme si la confiance des français
envers les médias changer radicalement
en un an
je pense au contraire nous aurions plus
d'avant davantage à étudier cette
influence sur du plus long terme
et puis c'est pas une influence univoque
ainsi je reprends le gars du fact
checking bien sûr il ya des personnes
qui ne vont pas adhérer au message des
médias quels qu'ils soient
alors les médias nous manipule tille
j'aurais envie maintenant que nous avons
spécifié un peu ce que nous entendons
par manipuler de spécifier davantage ce
que nous à entendons par les médias
qui sont ces médias dont nous parlons en
quoi considérons-nous qu'ils peuvent
avoir des intérêts à nous manipuler
nous pourrions délimité d'abord dans un
premier temps des médias d'information
des médias de masse
ça ne spécifieraient pas à mon avis
davantage de qui nous parlons
cela reste très vague très abstrait nous
pourrions identifier différents supports
la télévision internet la presse écrite
la radio
là encore ça reste plutôt abstrait on
peut aller encore plus loin en
distinguant des chaînes de télé de radio
des titres de presse entre eux et ce que
j'ai envie de dire c'est que ça a un
intérêt puisque en fonction de
différents critères nous allons alors
pouvoir distinguer différents types de
médias contre on pourrait utiliser par
exemple le critère de l'orientation
politique idéologique c'est un thème qui
est largement documenté il ya des médias
qui se revendique comme étant de gauche
de droite
d'autres qui le revendiquent pas et
qu'ils le sont
c'est un thème qui est largement
documenté il ya des collusions
politiques et donc on peut distinguer
les médias en fonction de ce critère
nous pouvons également distingué les
médias en fonction de leur mode de
financement de leur économie leur
fonctionnement économique certains
médias sont des médias dits de service
public ils sont financés par l'état
alors que d'autres médias sont financés
par le privé par la publicité par
désabonnement
quel impact cela peut-il avoir sur leur
ligne éditoriale par exemple en quoi
cela les différents sites il ou pas je
pense que ce sont des questions
intéressantes les groupes de presse
également
qui sont ces groupes de presse dans
quelle mesure intervienne deal sur les
contenus de ces
en média ou pain enfin je pense qu'on
pourrait aussi distinguer les médias en
tout cas journalistique justement sur la
question l'exercice du métier de
journalisme dans quelle mesure un
pigiste dans un statut précaire est il
en mesure justement de fournir une
information fiable lorsqu'il doit
rédiger un article de 1500 signes pour
le jour même sur un sujet qu'il connaît
à peine
on peut bien sûr différencier différents
statuts du journaliste dans différentes
rédactions par exemple différentes
contraintes d'exercice du métier en lien
ou pas avec les modèles économiques de
ces médias tout cela pour dire que
j'aimerais aller encore un pas plus loin
en réintroduisant la dimension humaine
dans la question parler non plus de
médias ou d'humains mais de médias et
d'humains de quitter le fantasme de
médias perçue comme une machine à
abrutir les masses montrer qu'il y à de
l'humain dans les médias et peut-être
que c'est un travail de pédagogie à
faire justement de la part de médias
dits mainstream traditionnel c'est de
montrer comment ça fonctionne comment
fonctionne une réunion de rédaction
comment choisissons-nous un thème que
nous allons mettre à la une
quels sont les moyens dont nous
disposons et comment les halles ou en
nous pour envoyer des journalistes sur
le terrain sont des questions qui
mériteraient que l'on puisse être
transparent à leur égard au delà de
décryptage en mode dessous des cartes
ont d'autre part j'aurais envie de dire
que tout le monde est un média
aujourd'hui il ya de plus en plus
d'acteurs plus ou moins alternatif qui
prennent la parole sur les médias
sociaux notamment qui diffusent des
idées et des messages ça m'interpelle
toujours de voir que c'est presque
qui aujourd'hui que les médias
traditionnels pourraient nous manipuler
pourrait avoir des intérêts à nous
tromper et que cette critique est
beaucoup plus timide beaucoup plus
discrète voire inexistantes
par rapport à ces nouveaux acteurs
alternatifs pourtant ils reproduisent
des fonctionnements des médias
traditionnels
la course au scoop le sensationnalisme
le buzz parfois des conflits d'intérêts
manifeste parfois un manque de
vérification de l'information
ça vaudrait le coup à mon avis de
considérer non pas les médias en un sens
limité mais d'élargir cette définition à
tous les émetteurs de coûts d'autant que
désormais à chaque récit correspond à
contrer si je prends l'exemple d'une
manifestation
vous avez une manifestation désormais
tout le monde est équipé du d'un
smartphone avec une caméra et cela se
traduit dans des forces de l'ordre qui
filme la manifestation et qui diffuse
une version des faits des manifestants
qui filme la même manifestation et qui
diffuse une autre personne est fait à
chaque récit encontre récit la critique
des médias
la manipulation potentiel par les médias
ne peut-elle pas s'appliquer ici aussi
et je pense que si nous prenons la peine
de considérer comme des médias de
nombreux autres émetteurs de contenus
même qu'ils ne sont pas journalistique
et bien nous pourrions leur trouver des
similitudes et sans doute aussi des
divergences avec des médias dits
mainstream alors même qu'ils se
distinguent soi-disant de ces médias
alors les médias nous manipule qui vous
aurez compris sans doute que je ne
souhaite pas répondre à cette question
de manière univoque unilatérale et
simpliste je pense qu'il faut aller
l'investigateur manière empirique
spécifiques
ça ne veut pas dire que il faut la
réduire à des responsabilités
individuelles ont proposé plus tôt de
dire qu'il y a une dimension sociale
sociologique à prendre il ya bien des
systèmes à critiquer mais pour moi il
faut étudier comment ça fonctionne au
sein de ces systèmes comment
interagissent les humains et les médias
pour comprendre les médias mon
invitation pour comprendre l'influencé
peut-être la manipulation des médias mon
invitation c'est de considérer la place
que nous occupons dans celui-ci thème
rôle que nous occupons noms cités les
relations complexes que nous y
entretenant c'est de comprendre ça que
nous soyons émetteur récepteur que nous
soyons journalistes ou citoyens
merci beaucoup
[Musique]